I hear it's video game history month
here on gamespot com the entire month of
May video game history month totally not
an arbitrary decision we made about six
years ago what we're doing on the show
all this month is we're going to focus
on games that are celebrating big
milestones okay milestone anniversaries
today it's GTA san andreas which came
out 10 years ago can you believe it ten
years and you believe this game came out
10 years ago thousand and for this
alright this is where IGN com is yeah I
found the IGN logo got in it's under the
freeway overpass so this is the Bay
Bridge so we're pretty close to where
gamespot offices would be yeah which
incidentally is close to where the IGN
offices are okay let's call this the
gamespot office sure this yeah there's
hookers walking around in front yeah
yeah finally together the gamespot
office yep excuse me would you like to
enter my vehicle it's totally safe my
damn I'm a damn i have only lightly run
you over this in my world is a
proposition get out of there so if
you've never been to the gamespot office
that's roughly what it's like when you
get here in the morning that limo is
really messing up traffic is what this
dude in the Mideast are you doing the
big red one bro get it together oh you
guys guys guys you are acting like some
fools guys you are big-time acting a
fool and I will not stand for this is
not getting do it get out of the grove
street whoa my homies these popping up
you guys are my homies popping off him
write it all up on you maybe it's
because you were menacing him with a
sword I don't know I don't think we'll
ever know I think I know it's probably
the thing about the sword just just
clean this up please that minigun really
goes off in a hurry doesn't it if he cut
his really vicious you're trying to jump
off the bridge with it Wow look at all
the guns and bodies yep okay oh man I
gotta destroy the evidence wow that
helicopter is right up
copy you have just really committed a
boner move you have made a bad decision
I just uh yeah I think so I think you
know what's up okay here we go plumbing
into the drink BASE jumping oh yeah yeah
your boat my boat is on fire without us
whoa Jala other boat none other boats
also on fire maybe I can steal this Cup
helicopter yeah how would how are you
gonna do that I don't know I'm gonna
knock it into the water first nope it's
dead don't get into blues me coppers
amer I chop these guys oh let me in let
me target is breaching currently excuse
me gentlemen I would just like to borrow
your boat temporarily look you continue
standing that's fine you just stay there
stay right there it'll be fine don't
worry about it I'm just gonna beach this
mother arguing the cops I realized that
I'm a maniac with a katana right look at
this look at this oh wow yeah that guy
owned his head off oh the chili dog guys
nodded to stand anymore he's just
standing that move okay chili dog guy
I'm very good i were there l don't be a
hero chili dog I you want a piece of
this oh I'll come get you don't even
care I'm rich and I'm crazy you are that
guy far-reaching crazy and also near
invincible danio dryers walking by right
oh no and no chili dog ah chili dog dude
oh I regret every life decision that
I've made danio dryer I don't want to
say I don't wanna you know misconstrued
anything but it looks to me passing by
to you might have some cheats huh I know
judging by your funky cheese and your
ability know your people it's just a
real it's just a real sketchy save file
i downloaded it might have like a perma
cheat enabled on it I love you sure you
like the wonder if you like my boots man
yeah my snakeskin cowboy boots are
pretty sick you guys head off yeah
that's my dad I forgot you could shoot
guys heads off in this yeah that guy
does
not gonna get ahead in business now yeah
definitely do a snipe time this is
definitely a good sniping time snipe
that guy in his testicles uh-huh I was a
little high that's whoa hey OH ding dong
oh oops haha evidence you guys is this
smile wow you guys leg into the gram
yeah come on dudes I'm gonna put a sweet
loaf I filter on this this won't be good
this music is dope Oh what kind of hours
do they have you working here I'm really
concerned about your you know cheetah
we're gonna cheat it you ready for this
rocket and I'm ready are you ready yep
Oh business time here we go what up high
road after all right this is like the
most fun exciting jetpacking you could
possibly do he's literally just standing
there holding a friggin joystick and his
legs are dangling career move you have
six stars how are you gonna get out of
this predicament I need to find a way to
die although I think I'm invincible so i
can't really die listen this i
understand that you were struggling with
the curse of being immortal but you need
to go down wear that pink neon is here's
here's what I don't get here's what I
don't say that pizza ranch nope it says
spread ranch oh you have eggs bread me
expres Drago in there that's a different
thing what doesn't he find out what this
is please can the six start awk and
you're not go in there when you when you
have an army attacking lower wanted
level haha sorry Joe later does so long
guys I was well nice all those dudes
were just like hello well I mean we're
here may as well go to the bank's web
page for a show hello sexy time alright
you maybe you want to put away your
shotgun I mean I just want to listen no
touching no touching touching I don't
know oh no oh wow God you get out
Ali get out get out Oh done bad
everything has gone back excuse me ma'am
oh no this lady is just trying to dance
oh okay sure exhausted one of her
compatriots excuse me officer I didn't
mean to do that I'm just gonna jet pack
my way out of here away wait so how long
do you think I was in that strip club
before I accidentally murdered person 11
second 11 seconds I think you made it
about 11 to 13 seconds look at me just
casually floating above the horizon so
we just took a pot shot at you so again
we got a jet pack idiot Kapow this is
called pimp my ride the CJ way no oh
[ __ ] there were cops there oh no oh no
ahh we're good we're good are we gonna
start a new yeah okay start a new you're
tired of living the obese life check out
this sick jump you ready yep Shh wow
that was a sick job now yeah right
that's a good place to pretty baller
move so there was a stretch I in college
when this was the only game that I
played for like four or five months Wow
because a being in college you don't
really have any money to speak of sure
and be who wants to study you know it's
certainly not me check this out ready
hey I like that I don't know I just want
to get my money's worth I don't kill
people for no reason Chris not a maniac
line myself up up up and got it is gonna
boom do insane stunts bonus you like
that try how the blackouts check this
out right if you're gonna Park it on top
of the building oh hahaha Bonnie would
like actually just decompose there I'm
gonna do some sick tricks I'm gonna do
what Ollie McTwist oh em I'm fighting
this weapon at you so that you will give
me your cheese scraps excuse me ma'am
listen I don't think you're gonna be
able to pick up a prostitute you almost
just run over and would you like to join
me for an evening of pleasure oh oh I
will not applied so getting hard little
not abide that oh yes did a terrible
thing oh and so did your buddy boy over
here oh yeah just a nice slow beat down
or ok shoot them should I go actually
pick one out we have four minutes left
four minutes in heaven where hits in
heaven yeah you're driving the intruder
so I think that pretty well suited he's
me kind lady I am be using in the manner
of a John would you be interested in a
gentleman caller skena am ma'am ma'am
ma'am would you like to earn some extra
dollars this evening can I interest you
in a little bit of this oh oh oh here we
go yeah just slow down and behave
yourself hi there i am looking for a
good time affirmative why don't you hop
in try not to develop i shoot her what
do you think is the button what makes
the prostitutes want to have sex with me
who's me excuse me wow she are you not
even interested in the only response to
passenger side doors so oh yeah I do
quick what let's look at what you gotta
press wise and what is hog you're in the
airport is apparently the place for
John's to cruise at night time yeah I've
been alright she's going on a brisk jog
yeah no I'm going to take her to a
secluded area are you gonna go to a
romantic spot I think you certainly am
yeah
all right is this the place is just cool
are we good we good ah drive onto the
beach I think there's a beach down there
you probably both both drown Oh what oh
no ditched oh boo couldn't even intrude
properly boo Oh shame all right lack of
shame lack of faith avoiding I for the
backs it's probably for the band kids
that's I oh no listen should I let her
live just because you were wasting her
time look at all her she's gonna get
herself killed I think you need to see
it you need to ask or her I need to ask
for her external wow that car stopped
miraculously as incredible bring right
I'll let her live because the thing is
after all the chaos I've caused on this
stream I've learned a thing or two okay
which is you don't need to kill
everybody oh that's one thing you know
some of you want uh that prostitutes
don't like airports yep also what is
this guy even doing blowing up cars and
having a very calm gunfight I think well
she's still alive so that's good I'm
like her gentleman protector in all the
chaos that is everyday life elric night
he has no don't worry oh she's okay is
non compos Wow no did she does she's got
sick she's good she's good ma'am this is
no nobody you today only way you you
stay away from my friend here I know you
have designs listen she is a nice lady
is trying to take care of a family okay
we're good we're good all right I think
we that's about as good as we're gonna
do on this stream I think we all learn a
thing or two on this the 10th
anniversary of GTA san andreas and then
next week on the Shan method it's going
to be video game history month this
video game history month another game
that's celebrating an anniversary 10
years 5 years 15 years we'll figure it
out tetris tetris it is not tetris but
thank you guys very much for watching
and we will see you next week at 11am
pacific so long 80